jonathan it's a real pleasure to get the
chance to speak to you
i've been uh absorbing a lot of your
work over the last week and uh i've
gotten a lot out of it it's been really
interesting
so i wanted to start with this question
of
what does it mean to say that the world
is becoming re-enchanted
well first of all it's great to it's
great to meet you i i understand that we
haven't met before
slightly so it's good to it's good to
kind of meet you again and i have also
uh been interested in the kind of stuff
you're doing in terms of
parkour and everything my son is really
into uh parkour so
that's kind of what prompted me to say
oh yeah i should talk to this guy
because i do find
i always find if i'd been younger i
would have definitely been into parkour
like
you know just a little younger anyway so
we can totally get you into it yeah
we'll talk about that after this yeah
i'm a little older i'm getting that
getting that permanent little belly it's
not a big belly it's like a little
anyways
all right so let's go for it uh so what
do i mean
the idea is that the uh
you could say something like the the
enlightenment or not just enlightenment
the whole process historical process
of of development created the
possibility for what we kind of call
you know materialism or rational
rationalism rational materialism
uh today um and it's
it's basically been a desire to see the
stability of the world in
in phenomena or manifestation and things
that you can quantify right
you can you can calculate you can
quantify you can count um
and my contention is that
the reason why it was able to kind of
last is because it was
it was trying to remove let's say the
mythological aspects of christianity but
it was still
surfing on that and so there were still
remainders of it or things taken for
granted which made it possible for
people
to pretend as if that wasn't there and
then kind of look at the world
just as phenomena and calculate and
quantify but as they were kind of
chopping
the tree that was holding them up at
some point things started to break down
and there really started to be like a
breakdown in terms of epistemology
uh which led to something like
post-modernism uh
to to this kind of this this instability
of
of interpretation but there's also
another breakdown which is
mirroring it which is a breakdown in
value and a breakdown in society where
we see society fragment and we don't
have things to kind of hold them
together
um and so it's so what you feel is that
this rational materialism is kind of
running its course it's becoming
impossible to hold at every level of
reality
because society is kind of breaking down
honestly because of the
type of thinking which led to to this
this this
approach uh now it's being replaced by
other weird mythologies and so
the the new atheists without even
realizing it
are being replaced by the woke and and
they almost like
opened the door for the without totally
i don't think they did it on purpose
uh but they they kind of set the stage
for kind of this woke uh
new mythology which is which is coming
in
so what my contention is it but it also
has to do with the
the these new um the fact that science
is trying to deal with consciousness
in a way that they haven't before
because they reached the edge in terms
of
the problem of of the quantum the
observer in the quantum realm and the
problem of
understanding the the what uh john
vervicky calls uh
uh what is it combinatorial explosion
and the problem of combinatorial
explosion and so now they have to
have to deal with things which until now
i've just been ignored
taken for granted right it's like you
don't see the glasses you're wearing
uh you don't notice them until things
start to get really weird and really
wacky and then you have to say wait wait
a minute
why are things so wacky then you start
looking at the lens through which you're
looking at the world and that's where we
are now
and in that movement what we're seeing
is that meaning is kind of
coming back in and storytelling image
making
all the tropes ritual all of these
things are going to return
because of the the crisis the crisis of
understanding that
the world actually has to be framed
somehow even even scientists are
starting to understand that
and so what is that frame going to be
and so it's so
so what i'm perceiving is that this is
happening in all kinds of ways it's not
just once like
the it's happening in in very strange
ways in terms of the return of religion
and this these all these kind of weird
fragmented new paganisms uh this this
desire to
be all these california buddhists like
there's just all these ways in which
this is pushing itself back into the
world for good and for ill in my opinion
but it's
to me it's definitely happening it
almost there's no
that's one of the reasons why i think
jordan peterson was so effective is
because
he was it he was scratching at something
which was already like an itch
that had been there for even a few
decades now and now is
everything's kind of coming together so
let me
restate that not i mean i think that i'm
largely in agreement with you
uh in what you've described um but i
want to see if my model kind of
is is the same as yours but
it seems to me and you know following
vervice work that that we have this
this drive towards rationality that
um maybe starts with with the kindness
and and we see it
playing out into descartes and newton
and all these people and it
it it it plays back and forth with the
enlightenment the counter enlightenment
you know empiricism romanticism and and
so these these two things
are it's not a linear trajectory but in
a certain way
like the late 90s and early aughts
seemed like
a period where you had um you had the
you had a an upwelling of religious
sentiment
right and the moral majority in america
and then you had the counter reaction to
it with the new atheists
and and science was
was delivering right we had the tech
revolution we had all of these things
that were
that were sort of making the world seem
like
like a rational approach was was gonna
win and i was part of this
like i grew up in the counter culture so
i grew up surrounded by people who were
into mysticism and astrology and they
were they were part of this break from
the rationalism of the west that
happened in the 1960s
and i self-selected into to basically
being
um you know a new atheist type myself
and i remember all the discussions that
were happening on the forums and
have you read a um an essay called um
the godlessness that failed by uh scott
alexander
i highly recommend it i think you get a
lot out of it but i mean he tracks
exactly what you're saying and how much
it happened like you can look at
peop if you if you dig below the surface
of the new atheist
there's this whole there's this whole
phenomena of people arguing for
atheism from that perspective online
yeah and these whole battles with it and
there were all these figures who
who were major figures even if they
weren't writing books that were new york
times bestsellers
but who are figures in that culture war
yeah and
there's a point at which new atheist in
which
atheist forums and sub forums and
platforms basically start adopting
something called atheism plus
and atheism plus is atheism plus social
justice it's not
yeah there's this realization that
atheism isn't an ethical platform
isn't it isn't it it's in nothing right
and people needed something yeah um
and but it's interesting like you can
look at the moment in the late 90s when
this happened
and you can actually see the you can see
how it was going to fail from the very
outset
because the the new atheists were in in
a large part reacting
ultimately not just in the late 90s but
like the big thing that made them really
react was was 9 11 like that was kind of
the
their high moment where it's like here's
this religious
thing that's coming back and it's and
it's going to destroy
us right it's it's attacking us it's
violent and it's all these things
and so the new atheists tried to
counter that with their kind of rational
atheism but they could never
account they were never able to account
to why destroying
the the two towers was
going to destroy america like they
didn't they could never understand
why it would do that because the reason
why those two towers
would become the break the beginning of
the breakdown of american culture was a
mythological one
it wasn't a material one like the it's
that it was the symbol of these two
towers what they were how high they were
what they represented in terms of the
god of america in terms of business and
in terms of money
all of this stuff was being attacked
and what what happened what happened was
a massive ritual like it was
it was then it ended up being a ritual
event which
led to many things and so the answer
which is
which is that the atheists gave couldn't
they could never answer that because it
happened
like what the terrorists wanted is
happening
this is what they wanted right they
wanted the world to to
to to realize they wanted to watch the
story of america break down
and they knew that by attacking their
highest symbol
right basically by by an act of
desacralization for the god of america
that they would succeed and they're
succeeding because
the the this this now back and forth
between
totalitarian security and desire for
freedom
has has now it's just moving back and
forth and there's no way
there's no way to stop it anymore
because there's nothing to answer
and also because that god the the the
god of economy is not a sufficient god
it's it can't hold the society together
that's one of the things we're realizing
trade
is not enough to hold the society
together um so anyways go ahead with the
with the 80s and plus but i just wanted
to kind of interject that and to see
why it it was they they never understood
what they were dealing with
and i don't agree with the terrorists
obviously i don't agree with them
but i can understand what they were
doing yeah i mean
i'm i'm reminded of of uh listening to
dan carlin talk about the history of the
syrian empire and how
when they conquered a new people like
one of the first things they did was
take down
all the statues of their gods and
basically take them back to their
their own city and put them in
subservience to their overarching god
right there's a there's a symbolic power
to this act and i think the idea of
of capitalism as a god um
is actually a really profound one but
let's let's dig into that a little bit
more
um as we go through see how to finish
the thought that i was on
is basically atheism
as a sort of cultural trend was gobbled
from within
by social justice and the people who
were
supporting this kind of militant atheism
ended up
almost a mass going over and really
kind of particular figure you can look
at is pz myers
pz meyer spent all of his time arguing
against creationists
up until i think 2011 2012 and then all
of a sudden it switches over and now
it's about the racists and the
misogynists
the the homophobes and the transphobes
right and all of his writing is now
there um and
and so i share the sense that
that religion keeps popping up right
like
her i remember i was i was involved in
crossfit in the early days of crossfit
and there was the sense all of a sudden
that like crossfit's a cult
right like it's many things right and it
can be a great form of exercise i'm not
i'm not
sort of smashing down on all the all the
crossfitters but but like
people start treating it as their place
to
have an experience of the sacred right
and i remember identify with it yeah
like they make it they're part of their
uh
large part of their identity you can see
it when you see someone does crossfit
you can usually recognize them pretty
fast
not so much anymore but when it was like
at that point you could just like
be like oh yeah that guy yeah i mean you
know
the joke was like you know uh how do you
know someone's a crossfitter
like don't worry they'll tell you right
the joke also works with vegans right
and yeah yeah yeah that's the other the
other experience that i had of like
of like okay wait like religion's
popping up all over because i remember
sitting down with this guy
and and talking about veganism and he
was trying to sort of like he
he was a new zealand veganism and he was
moving through the parkour community in
in england and and he he's like okay i'm
a sustainability
vegan right he i i choose veganism
because it's better for the planet and i
was like
well here's why that's not probably the
case
right um and then he's like well
i'm uh i'm a health vegan and i was like
well
here's why that's probably not the
healthiest for you and then he was like
well i'm an ethical vegan laid out
i laid out why why it's
possible and maybe i'm wrong like i'm
not claiming i'm wrong but i made an
argument why
why you know there are more animals that
are destroyed
through farming you know um for soybean
and corn than
would otherwise be and you have to
utilize more land if you're not
utilizing mixed farming system
and it just hit a wall
and then it was like well i'm just a
vegan because right yeah
and i was like oh there's there's no
rational argument that will
convince you out of this because this is
your sacred value this is what you
you worship right um but the ethical
vegan is the greatest vegan because
the ethical vegan is reinstating the
human
sacred without even realizing is saying
that we do not participate
we are above natural processes and we
kind of stand above them
and then we look at them from above kind
of like from this this high mountain
and then we we we choose not to
participate in the in the violence
because obviously animals eat each other
like
animals you know that the fate of an
animal in the in the wild is
is is pretty bleak like in terms of how
it's going to end its life
and so the idea that the idea that
someone would think that it's ethical
to not kill animals means that they
stand above like angels above the world
and they kind of look at it from
a spiritual place um so it's just
interesting because veganism exists in
religious traditions
but it's specifically like monks are
they're not vegan but they're definitely
vegetarian in the christian uh tradition
and i think in buddhism and in many
other
you know and the jains are like they're
they're basically he should have just
said i'm a jane
like that's what he should have said
like i'm really i what i really
am is a kind of a religious person but
anyways all right keep going sorry
yeah so
this one's a touchy one but you you
already mentioned wokism but i mean not
like it was really striking to see this
come up after
george floyd right and the washing of
the feet and
the like i i was walking through seattle
and i saw
this altar that someone had created in
their front yard
with like martin luther king's name and
george floyd's name and
uh tawanna bradley and and and and
trayvon martin
and all of these all of these slogans
and all of this artwork right like like
like pieces of glass and mirrors and
feathers and like i said i actually sent
a picture of it to john
and said like this is an altar right
like is there any other way to interpret
this but as an altar and he's like yeah
it's an altar it's clearly an altar um
and so it was like i had this sense that
you know i described this to him so if
i'll
tell you a little story a friend of mine
who's a gay black man
he um you know after the george floyd
protests
you know he had all of these people
calling him and asking him about you
know is he okay
is he okay is he okay right and he's
like
this has been my experience of america
like i've had this expectation of the
police
the whole time right like nothing's
changed for me but all of a sudden this
one thing happens and everyone's
concerned
about me and then
and then he had this sense that like
well he felt at first like all these
people loved him and were his friends
and then he had this disillusionment
where his sense was
actually they were just calling him to
basically be shriven of their sins
right and i told him that i think that
basically
um this movement the blm movement is a
kind of
it's a it's a kind of uh reflection of
christianity
where the suffering of christ on the
cross has been replaced by the suffering
of the african-american
right and and and the thing about that
that's really terrifying to me is that
african-americans are actually then
forced into a priestly
class right where their role is
instrumental for white americans to be
able to
release their sins by checking their
privilege because checking your
privilege is just confessing your sins
that's what it yeah that's a it's
exactly what it is and it's and it's
different from christianity because
christianity has a universal form where
there there is an absolution and also
the priest himself like
if you watch if you listen to look at a
christian liturgy there's a moment in
the liturgy where the priest will turn
to the people and will say forgive me
brothers and sisters
and there's an understanding that this
is not a one just a one way
thing where we all participate in this
in this uh
this desire to forgive each other and to
kind of cover each other's sins so that
we can come together and be
one right it's the point the point of
like the point of
asking forgiveness for your sins is to
then be in communion with people it's
not just a moral
finger wagging or some kind of getting
rid of a feeling of guilt
it actually is supposed to bind you but
if it doesn't
then like you said it becomes a very
very dangerous
situation where you have one group of
people that has ultimate
authority and then another group of
people that just
need to get that get their forgiveness
from those and that's it
and so and and there it doesn't even
seem to be a way to fully
be absolved in that in that movement
like a perpetual guilt
yeah there's no there's no redemption
right no
it's a dark it's a dark enlightenment
right and
um there's another great book that i
like called um um
oh professing uh professing feminism or
no
i'm sorry i forgot it's by daphne corgi
and our daphne patel and
corgi um but they basically talk about
the rise of gender critical theory
in women's studies and they talk about
it as like there's eventually this
this realization that that
the young women mostly who are entering
this are having a conversion experience
like a christian conversion experience
except there's no hope
right what they're being told is that
patriarchy is
is in every every ounce of every moment
of everything that is done and that it's
always going to be there and it means
that everything is
everything is essentially dependent on
the creation of their suffering
yeah and that's that's actually an
extraordinarily
um psychologically destructive way to
view the world yeah yeah
and that's why you see like the the
image of the critical
this this kind of radical feminist is is
a sad one like in just in terms of you
know how they they
how they present themselves like their
mimicry their faces
you can feel like this deep anger and
despair which rules over them you know
like they just live in a world of anger
and despair
yeah so um
so if if somebody what should we do yeah
so so if we if we identify that that
religion is popping up
everywhere right
what is what is the symbolic world why
why is it necessary to understand at
this point in order to
to move forward through the breakdown
well so the idea what
so when we look at this what we see is
something which is
is a kind of disease version of religion
or a kind of completely
whack whack version of religion but
what we can help us understand is that
it's manifesting something which is
inherent to the human person
and cannot be gotten rid of that is the
desire to
participate in in common purposes
those that's what being a human is and
in order for that to happen like in
order for us to be able to participate
together to recognize each other
as being part of a group there has to be
a totem which appears above it there has
to be something
which is beyond the group which will
bind it together
you know and so i i often use the image
of a
of a sports team like a sports team is a
religious venture
yeah you know and and everything about
it is is religious
and there are certain sacred things you
have to be careful even it becomes
superstitious like
you know so many sports people are
engaged in actions which
for a rational materialist would be
considered superstitious but it's really
just all these
token behaviors which are there to
manifest the unity
of the group and there's a sense in
which the unity even of the fans for
example
will participate in the winning of the
team
and this is true like it's true it will
actually work which is why teams
lose yeah you know will lose at uh in
another city
but will win on in their own city
because the coherence of the the fans
and their participation will participate
in the winning of the team and so all of
it
is really this kind of coming together
but i also want to point to is that this
is
actually completely inevitable we this
is what makes us human
and so now that we realize this
we have to be able to deal with it
appropriately so if we pretend if we
try to ignore or suppress this reality
of
either we'll be doing it without
realizing it we'll participate in it
unconsciously or it'll actually come
back
almost like a like a hydra it'll come
back in a very dark
dark and dangerous way because these
desires
they also they also have a very
dangerous and dark undertone if we're
not careful
you know because this desire to join
together
it means you exclude necessarily that's
what it is
and so inclusion and exclusion is is a
is
is a dangerous it's a dangerous thing
and it can lead to violence and war and
all of this
and so if we need to so the idea is this
is inevitable and the kind of
the weird like the weird globalist uh
desire
to to create this like one world thing
or whatever to avoid it
is not going to avoid it it's going to
fragment at lower levels that's what the
story of babel is
the story babel is this desire to to say
oh
like if we just create one thing if we
just like have one
massive group and then we're all in the
group then it'll then it'll work but
that's not how it works
if you don't have intermediary groups if
it doesn't
manifest itself fractally is what i i
try to talk about
it's like you need you need layers of
unity so it's like
you your family your city your group and
then your religious unity and
you know you have all these layers of
unity if you try to remove those so that
we're all in just one thing
uh we're gonna we're gonna rip each
other apart
we're gonna rip each other's eyes out at
some point we're going to start to
fear the your neighbor you're going to
start to to create weird groups of unity
and then
there's going to be a civil uh basically
civil war is what's going to happen
it's sort of happening right i mean yeah
exactly i mean that's why i can say it
without flinching because
it's already happening and it can get a
lot worse because we're not even
it's not even started it's it's going to
get worse
yeah there's a you know there's
i think there's survey data that shows
that like you know the the sense of how
good race relationships in this country
are
is is is going down very fast and
um and then obviously the polarization
between left and right has reached a
level that's
that's really absurd um and it's
interesting because
let's say when people talk like let's
say you think of the civil war the u.s
civil war
or you think of other civil wars in
history usually what it is it's like
there are competing groups within
the unity right so there are two tribes
that are that are together in war two
families two big families that are
together
in one one unity and then the tension
between
these two tribes you know becomes so
strong that the unity can't hold anymore
and then one has to defeat the other or
they have to split or they have to do
something like that
uh but now it's it's all across the
system
so it's not like the north and the south
yeah right it's
it's everywhere and it's it's your
neighbor
and it's in the cities and it's in the
it's in the it's the cities versus the
the outside it's the it's the it's it's
not even even just parts of the country
it's like within the country
it's happening at every level so that
kind of civil war it's
is my goodness you have no idea what
could come
we've got
white versus people of color we've got
asian versus black we've got
you know the whole thing that's going on
with the jews right now is really scary
um and and then you have rural
urban you have low income high income
you've got
men versus women you've got unmarried
women versus married women
totally different perception of things
right now
so there's lots of there's lots of
fragmentation um
there's a one thing that's ironic and i
i just wanted to bring this up quickly
another essay by slate star codex
worth worth reading is called i can
tolerate everything but the out group
um and it's about this idea that that
the the sacralization of tolerance is
actually allowing
a sense of intolerance of anyone who
doesn't
hold that value as most sacred that
is paradoxically extremely intolerant
yeah
i mean it's it's it's so funny when you
encounter it it's like
you just want to laugh it just so you
don't cry like i remember meeting a
really
kind of woke person at an event where i
was talking about jordan peterson
and he came to me he was kind like
because we were talking about jack
davida and the idea of hospitality of
like
radical hospitality which did not talk
about this like absolute openness
and i was trying to argue with him how
impossible that is but he was saying
like this is the way we need to go
then he then he says this little thing
he says well obviously we're not going
to be
radically hospitable to fascists but
then he keeps going i'm like oh okay
what just happened great what just
happened yes
not everyone but the the person that
i've decided is my enemy
yeah exactly right yeah which is where
christianity is brilliant
well that's the idea right it's it's
it's it's like it be
it turns gets turned inwards and then it
becomes about self-sacrifice like that
becomes the mode
of of let's say the mode of
of uh and the person that was killed and
and brought out of the city
is is god himself and then that
plays itself in your own self where it's
like i need to
i need to sacrifice myself instead of
sacrificing the the neighbor or the
other yeah
the scapegoat that's very good the self
so
i want to go back to the religion as a
team sport idea or team sport as a
religion idea because i
another another resource that i really
i'm getting a lot from is a book called
the righteous mind by
jonathan height have you have you read
that yeah well i haven't read the whole
thing but i haven't
i've read parts and listened to many of
his lectures yeah so i mean
you know it's really resonant with what
we're talking about because
you know he has a chapter in there i
mean basically it's about understanding
the out group right and it's about
understanding what
what the telos of different groups
actually is like one of the things i
told you before the call that
i wanted to have this call with you
really in particular once i heard you
with rationality rules and
adam printed because i felt like i was
able to operate
the conceptual framework that they were
playing in
but i was more open to the conceptual
framework that you're playing in and i
wanted to be able to to produce that
right but i think from a rational
materialist mindset like
this chat the chapter you're right it's
called religion as a team sport
really helps understand because he's
essentially saying that
biologically and culturally we've
evolved
we've evolved this capacity to act in
groups
and the research shows that that having
a religious system
improves that and religions are probably
selected over time for their ability
to help people act in groups right
and there's always the thing about a
group is that it has an out group and
this is part of your
you know i think what you talk about a
lot which is really brilliant is
in order to define a group you have to
have an out group
and the default human tendency towards
the treatment of the outgroup is
complete alienation this is something
that people
i think it would be really useful for
people to read the anthropological
literature a lot more closely and not
with a sort of noble savage
gloss on it because i feel like
sometimes i i like people will read it
an anthropological thing and they'll be
like oh man their lives are so amazing
i'm like
i read the same book as you and i don't
know if you read the part where the
the man just kills a child for no reason
or
or the woman is beaten by multiple
husbands because that that's part of
this tribe that you've just told me is
like
the perfect example of egalitarianism
but um
but one of the things that you find is
that the that very often in tribal
cultures the name for
people outside the tribe is just not
people yeah they're not human
they're not human and they don't have
any there's no
sense of moral obligation to them yeah
and i think yeah which is why like
the type of torture that they conflict
on someone which is from outside the
group is like
no there's no limits you saw that in
native culture here in canada where it's
like they if they caught someone from
the other tribe they could do anything
to them
yeah yeah absolutely um
and it wasn't like it actually wasn't it
was interesting because it wasn't a
racial thing
it was a ritual reality and so they
could
ultimately adopt someone from another
tribe and once they were adopted then
they were like oh
they're they're they in the end group
but unless that happened then they were
they were
inhuman and they were just basically
something
to be acted upon so yeah yeah i mean i
think
there's definitely a truce to the idea
that that the way that we
perceive race or the way that race was
perceived say in the
late 19th century early 20th century has
this massive social construction
and it's un using this underlying group
competition psychology and it's mapping
it to
to certain physiological differences in
order to
you know for for a variety of reasons
right historically
but it's it's not a default setting to
to automatically treat those physical
characteristics as the most
most important aspect of someone's
identity
yeah yeah and also i mean the the racism
itself is
a modern concept like it is a scientific
uh
it's a scientific uh take on
the on the ancient perception of
difference but it
but now we've made it into these
scientific defendable categories
so scientific racism is is most
the nazis were more like scientific
racists than they were like the ancient
people and how they understood uh
difference or understood
stranger and that kind of stuff yeah
so um
so i wanted i wanted to get into your
idea of the
the cosmological frame like i think the
conversation we've had so far
well maybe i can just into what you're
talking about about jonathan height and
let's say the difference between what
jonathan height is saying
and let's say a proper religious
understanding is that jonathan height
perceives that there are these axes you
know that people will
elevate something a virtue or someone or
something and then they will process
around that
that reality right they will they'll
circumambulate around
a common point and then that will create
cohesion in the group
but jonathan heights seems to treat that
as almost like arbitrary
as if as if like whatever it is you
decide is gonna is going to
be up there then that's going to be the
thing that's going to join together
it's going to play out but this is in
terms of a religious understanding you
could understand that
it is perceiving this which led to
something
like the what we call the monotheistic
religions which is actually that
if you if you follow like i was actually
just reading i was reading fidris
recently uh plato's feeders and
in in it socrates talks about how the
followers of certain gods
will seduce their lover in a way that
resembles
the god and so it's like if you follow
zeus then the way you will approach your
lover
will be like zeus if you follow you know
if you follow
this god then then you will kind of
approach your lover in that way
and this is this you're going to be yeah
exactly and just
aggression if you're pan let's go to the
woods
so there were different so you just but
it's mostly the idea to understand that
like whatever it is that you follow
you subject yourself to that right so
if you like you say when we talked about
the idea of crossfitters it's like
people who who follow crossfit or
worship crossfit
they become crossfitters it's not
arbitrary they actually
they actually embody the thing that
they're worshiping
yeah so so right they become the body of
the thing they're worshiping
and so this is the movement let's say
towards
monotheism which is that okay we realize
that there are aspects of reality
that are fragmented and if we if we
worship those as the highest thing
then we we embody something but it ends
up being in conflict
with something else because it's it's a
fragmented aspect of reality which is
why like so the greek cities would just
fight all the time
and even though they went to the
olympics or whatever they would fight
every year there would always be wars
between the greek cities because
they were subject to different
principalities and those principalities
they didn't necessarily elevate above
there was like a competition between
them
whereas the idea of like a monotheistic
thing is like
let how do these all these things come
together
higher up can we have something which
unites them
in a higher way and then you have the
kind of neoplatonic idea
being itself and then love right
because love is the manner in which
multiplicity exists
as one so you can have both multiple
and one and so then you kind of go you
keep going and then you have this idea
like let's say in christianity the
revelation of the trinity
which is the notion that there's in you
there's a mult thing that's both
infinitely multiple and infinitely one
at the same time
it seems like a total contradiction but
you realize actually no if we worship
that
then we can both have multiple
and one because if you if you if you're
too much in unity you have a problem
which is that
difference starts to get sucked into the
unity people become like carbon copies
of each other like in communist
countries
but if you just worship multiplicity
then all of a sudden things start to
break down like
like we're seeing now and then fault
lines start to appear people start to
fight amongst each other
so what's the highest thing we can
worship it's something which is both at
the same time
i want to try to ground this in biology
right like
my frame often is going to go back to
evolutionary biology
but but i think like when you talk about
um multiplicity and immunity
um that's the right words right yeah
like that ends up
having a very sort of mythological frame
sounding to it and i think it's
hard for a rational materialist to grasp
it like i literally feel like i didn't
get what you were actually saying until
last night
okay um
and then i was like oh this is exactly
what verveiki is saying
right verveiki describes that as the
process of
of of diversification and integration
yes so every process
that that complexifies has to both
diversify functions while uniting them
under some
overarching talos right yeah so
simultaneously like it has to be
constantly happening at the same time
yeah and and then this is what with what
height talks about in the righteous mind
is the idea that
um that cooperation always suffers
a uh a free rider problem right
but we've we've actually been able to
move up
through these levels of cooperation
right the single cells
first you have like mitochondria that go
into cells right and they are they're
two different things and then all of a
sudden they learn to cooperate and not
default off of each other
and then single cells become multiple
cells
and then those become organs and so like
that's that's your developmental process
you started as a single cell
and then then what can happen there's
two things that can happen one
one sort of cell can just start
start replicating itself and trying to
turn everything into itself
that's cancer and you die the other
thing that can happen
is your your systems can go to war with
each other that's
autoimmune disease that can also kill
you yeah right
and so we have these these two
directions that you're talking about the
direction
of of of of sort of
collapse into a single thing which
destroys
the overarching thing yeah which is what
they tried to do in the matrix with
agent smith like that's what agent smith
was supposed to be
he's supposed to be like this this like
the tyranny of
of of a specific thing that tries to to
make everything into itself
yeah cancer basically cancer yes it
takes everything over so
so i think that it's really helpful to
be able to look at that
from these two different frames right
now
i think that part of what makes
your world be your your world view and
not say
jordan peterson like i think a lot of
people are just mapped the way that you
think to jordan peterson yeah
like that was something that came up in
those two conversations it was like wait
you're actually a religious person who
believes in god
yeah i'm not jordan peterson that's for
sure um
is is that you think that there's a
reason why
framing it as in that mythological
realm rather than in the biological
analogy
actually works better but it's not just
that
it's it's that you can
one of the difficulties people seem to
for one of you can see it top down and
bottom up
you're seeing it top bottom bottom up
let's say and that's fine with me like
i'm fine with bottom up
but the thing is that you have to keep
going that's the
that's the point it's like can you keep
going that is
there a way to start bottom up from like
let's say quantum
possibility field of possibility and
then move
all the way to being itself
that is how all this multiplicity joins
together towards unity but then it also
continues in the human
person but it continues across human
persons
that's what a city is right a city is
the same as a cell
it's a it's a trans-personal being that
that is is is engaging in those rules of
complexity that you mentioned
you know constantly diversifying
constantly unifying and
it's a it's a it's a messy process like
it it's not always totally clean but
it's happening or else cities
wouldn't exist and then countries etc
etc and so
the idea is that there there has to be a
way for it to continue to scale up
and then if you scale that up to its
limit
that's what you you get to you you end
you inevitably get to something like
love or infinite love or or the divine
trinity
that's what you will get to because one
of the problems that i see is that
people
see it in biologically but then they
stop at some level some reason it's like
keep going man
it keeps going like keep going up and at
some point it also becomes true in the
world of intelligence
so it's like it's not it doesn't it's
not only biological
you'll notice that ideas also have that
same
pattern where ideas have
have places where they unify in places
where they they complexify
so if you think just any any concept or
any
any uh let's say abstract uh notion will
also have that in it
it'll have it it'll have an aspect of
complexification and unification
then you can keep going in that world
sure so like just to to
to throw an example for people right you
could look at parkour
and you could you could divide it into a
series of
of sub disciplines the different people
practice
so there's like rail flow and there's uh
bar swinging and then there's like all
the tree jumping in the wood right nike
and you could see those things as
essentially separate and they could they
could even like separate like
someone might decide they're just gonna
go be a railflow guy and they're not
gonna mess with the rest of parkour
and then you can be like well okay well
parkour is a movement
art and now you see that it's unified
with other movement arts right so now
now you see that it's in some
overlapping category that contains also
martial arts and dance yeah
yeah skateboarding like all these kind
of movement arts and then they move like
you said it moves into
something which is even higher and then
you could then that could keep going
like it could keep going up if you were
if you were capable of
perceiving how everything moves into
being let's say
so that's exactly what i'm talking about
yeah yeah so
so i had this so growing up in the
community that i did
i the word spirituality makes the hairs
on the back of my neck
right like
when when someone says spirituality i
feel like they're about to try to sell
me [ __ ]
yeah right like they're gonna i
understand no i see what you i know what
you mean
um they're gonna tell me
like spirituality to me is telling me
that it's really important
to
i'll give you a really precise example
when i was growing up there was a
certain
people within my community who would say
you create your own reality
yeah there's this idea that that like
and those people
would then turn around and do heinous
[ __ ] and say that the reason
that you felt their [ __ ] was heinous
was because you were creating your own
reality yeah that's horrible
right that that that just drove me crazy
and so i've always like at a certain
point the the stuff that i was teaching
started being like well parkour has some
kind of profound transformational impact
on you well how do i understand that how
do i help people
get that how do we get more of that and
someone's like well you're a spiritual
teacher it's like well no
because those [ __ ] are are are full
of [ __ ]
yeah and i'm trying not to be yeah
and but then i had this i was reading
two books one is a book called
the spell of the census by david abram
and that's about phenomenology
that's very much inspired by merlot
ponte and the other one is a book called
uh um what the robin knows
and it's about uh it's about bird
languages
and i had the sense of exactly what
you're describing i believe which is
that
when you walk through the woods you hear
birds singing
and you can tune into a bird or you can
turn into the birds
and all of the birds together actually
contain
an intelligence that's more than
the single bird okay so if all the birds
go quiet you know there's a predator in
the area
yeah right and so there's a neural net
and you can you can pay attention to
where the quiet is
and where the noise is and you can pay
attention to where the alarm calls are
and all of these birds are like they're
they're little neural nets that are
communicating to other neural nets
through sound
that are that are giving you information
about the environment
yeah and hunter foragers are
extraordinarily attuned to this and they
will be like okay i know where
these animals are because i'm listening
to the signals from the forest
and i'll say well that the easiest way
to conceptualize that is that's the
spirit of the bird
it's the spirit of the birds and then
you could understand that the spirit of
the birds
is is a sub-segment of the spirit of the
forest
but there's all this other information
between the trees and the other animals
and all of that kind of rises up to
something
above that yeah and i believe that
that's what you are referring to when
you
talk to something about something like
powers and principalities and then we
could
we could understand facebook and google
and social media
as as all of these things right yeah
especially now it seems like we're
building something like we're building
some kind of uh
of a body of a god that's for sure it
seems pretty obvious by now
so interesting we're building we're
building new gods
right it's really hard like but this is
not new
this is what pagans did all the time
like this is what that's what making
they would make statues of a god and
then they would
they would open its nostrils so that it
could become
the center of a community and then
people would
embody the god like they would they
would become worshipers
and like i told you about in the how
socrates describes the followers of
certain gods as embodying but
the statue would be like the
would be like the place where our
attention would go like all our
attention kind of moved towards that
that embodiment and and that's would be
part of the how we would
how we would manifest the god and so
it's like
the google is
is definitely acting that way and what's
interesting about
google and facebook too what's
interesting about them is that they
they're pretending they're
they're all there are there's like a
priestly cast that's whispering
there's like a priesty class whispering
the will of god
and we and we can't they don't want it
to know that it's there but it's there
and so it's like the google searches are
obviously tainted
towards whatever that priestly cast
wants us to to believe
and so all the actually all the really
negative stuff about about religion that
people
caricature like this idea of this like
greasy cassidy wants to control
everybody
it's like this is what's happening right
now if you want to know like this is a
and and they don't have uh they don't
have something above them
which is supposed to be their judge if
there's nothing above them which is
uh there isn't a tradition or something
before them or above them which is
telling them
like so like let's say a priest abuses
his power he can do it in in the
catholic church let's say
but everybody knows that he's wrong even
if
you know he can do it and it's going to
happen all the time but everybody
recognizes that it's wrong whereas now
there is no there is no ultimate there
is nothing above to kind of
well there is i believe but like at
least in their perception like they're
the arbiters of reality really
so that's scary stuff and we you know we
could say that
there's a telos to social media oh yeah
there's a there's a there's a goal which
it is serving
and at a first approximation maybe that
is is capturing of attention
but that yeah that's but that's it's
also understanding how reality works
it's it's really in a way we're in a
good place because because social media
and
and google is showing us that the world
is in
many ways functions through attention
that it's actually made of attention
and now once you realize that the world
is made of attention to a certain extent
then again ancient religious rituals
will
become less arbitrary to you you know
the idea that
to attend to something which is beyond
you to do it together
right to stand together and then to
attend to something which is beyond you
is actually has a actually has a
a causative function like a causative
role it actually causes unity
in that group
it's a different kind of causality it's
hard because materialists understand
that there are causalities of like
billiard balls hitting each other
but there's a type of causality which is
a causality of
of of unity right this is the formal
cause that
that that uh aristotle talked about like
there's a
there's something which brings you
together yeah
so in my conversations with verveiki and
vander clay
we've talked about your perspective and
in particular talked about your
perspective also in relationship
with with david abrams perspective and
the the place where i get hung up
is i find what you have to say extremely
insightful
right but there's a point at which you
assert that a pattern of being exists
right this is just the pattern right the
pattern is heaven and earth
the pattern is there's the unstructured
potential outside of heaven and earth
masculine is this feminine it is
associated with this
um and it's annoying
huh that's annoying
and and my question is always
how do you es what's the epistemology
that allows you to assert that right
like i think that
in your conversation with um with
with stephen winford you you basically
i think make it i wish i could replay
what you said exactly but you made a
case that essentially that
he has no way of establishing the good
that his frame
doesn't allow him to establish the good
and that he's not fully
conscious of that right that i think was
a key part of your argument
so it's like you're telling me that my
thing doesn't
doesn't serve the good but you don't you
don't know how to describe your own good
and like you know based on on on
heights book i would say that harm
reduction is actually the good that he's
talking about
right it's the closest to to the god
that he's worshiping but he couldn't
actually tell you
that but i would say that reciprocally
i still don't understand how you
establish the true
sorry you broke down could you repeat
that i said um reciprocally i would say
i don't know how you establish the true
like i i i sort of like you you asked
him where do you stand right
and i would say that i don't have the
same certainty about where i stand it
that you do
like i feel like i stand within
scientific epistemology
right as a rational materialist and that
i
recognize that that frame that set of
axioms
doesn't give me everything that i need
and i suspect based on what that frame
tells me
that a lot of what i'm relying on is
actually christian
but it's that it's this ghost of
christianity or the bones of
christianity that i'm standing on
yeah um i don't know that i can that i
can
say that with 100 clarity right i don't
know
i think that's a quite difficult
question to answer really well yeah
but but that's where i would say that
i'm standing but i would say that
that i that i that i believe that we
have a good
way of asserting a truth claim within
scientific epistemology and that we have
to be able to understand and utilize
that system because it's what allows
this technology that we're speaking
on to work and if we if we allow
if we allow sort of participatory
mystical phenomenological
thing to colonize all the way down into
the propositional level
that runs a risk of collapsing it and
it's already happening right science is
already like all of these
all of these little religions that are
popping up they're trying to colonize
and crush science
yeah social justice does not want
science to operate in science
it wants it to operate fully in service
it's lysynchoism
right um so
but then you'll realize that science at
least the kind of uh the
the image of science that people think
has never really
manifested right that it has always been
serving
goals like other goals and and what
social and what the social justice
people want
is only that science serves their goals
uh
and and and by doing that it appears to
us like a clash because
we're like not in the same world and so
like it's a different world and they're
saying
we want these technical uh physical
descriptions to serve
our our goals let's say uh
but it that i think has pretty much
always been the
the case like it's always kind of been
there
so i've made the argument to verveiki
that
that i think that if we're going to kind
of survive the western that
if western civilization and what has
given rise to the world system that it's
given rise to is going to survive
probably the best thing that we can do
is in some sense recover christianity
because it's the only
religious system that has a history of
allowing science to fully
develop within its under its eaves right
and his counter argument is that the
islamic golden age and
you know i i don't think i have an
answer to that but
um but but i do think there's something
there and i think
you know there's a claim that that
really that that science is sort of
necessarily
nested within a religious frame yeah
that's definitely what i
what i what i believe um but maybe i can
maybe i can how can i say this so maybe
i can help you
uh with the the problem of when i say
heaven and earth and all these things
yeah the the first thing that
the first thing that we need to notice
is that
the terms that are used when i talk
about it are always analogical they're
always
and so you can even hear it often in my
voice so i'll say
i say you can say something like and
then i'll say something because
the pattern is a is a pure intuition and
and i don't know what to say uh besides
that and that's going to be annoying for
a lot of
kind of materialist but there is a sense
and it's a some it's a universal sense
it's not just in christianity it's an
almost in every religious
system that humans have a capacity
to intuit the the
reality to intuit the real pattern and
that intuition is not
reason it reason flows from that
intuition
and so so it's it's a direct grasping of
of the of the pattern but then you can't
you can't when you when you bring it
back down into the world of
manifestation you have to translate that
or you have to
you have to embody it you have to give
it form and then you can
talk about different patterns and the
only way to help people
see or to intuit the the actual pattern
is to i mean there are different ways
like
zen cohen's or like the different ways
to kind of provoke
that in people the way that i try to do
it is to give you a bunch of analogies
that you don't think
that you don't think fit together but
like all these examples of things you
don't think
actually have something in common and
then all of a sudden you
see that they have something in common
and it gives you a little glimpse and it
appears to you like an insight
like a spark you have this like scent
that it's coming together
and often you can't hold on to that
it'll it'll kind of get it
and then it'll go away but but that
insight is described in every single
religious system that ever existed it's
like this kind of this glimpse of
reality and then
then this kind of fade away and so it's
going to be annoying what i'm going to
say but it's like that's what my truth
claim is grounded in
i don't know what to tell you your tooth
correct your truth claim is grounded in
a
in a personal intuition it's grounded in
an intuition
which then becomes verified as you can
see the intuition
embodied in different levels of reality
but so that's how you that's how you
verify right so you
you so you have the intuition and then
you have to then you have to see
if it finds body so if it works at the
personal level at this at the
civilizational level at the family level
uh
if if it works in stories if you find it
in stories you can find it in ritual
if you find if you're able to see how
this intuition embodies itself
then you're close like you're closer to
a real pattern than if it's just this
weird like freak thing that you
that you kind of you can people can have
intuitions but often they don't
they're not right like they don't
actually verify when you
try to embody them and so so there is a
there's almost like there is a kind of
scientific
it's close to actually how science work
because people don't realize that
scientists often don't
find things by digging in the dirt
they have intuitions yes absolutely and
then they verify whether or not by
digging in the dirt it'll
it'll pan out and that's exactly the way
that i that i work it's like
i have an intuition and then i try to
verify it at different levels
um so but it's a little different than
it's a little different than the
the scientific way but it's nonetheless
trying to find
the pattern embodied let's say yeah
so i i heard two things there one was
kind of an appeal to pragmatism right
sorry you have to repeat that i
keep breaking down so you said you heard
two things
yeah one is an appeal to pragmatism
right and
basically this very it really sounds a
lot like peterson's argument and there's
two aspects to peterson's argument one
is
um is is you kind of know that a pattern
is true when it works for you
but it works well enough but but the the
corollary to that claim would be that he
would say that
that we only ever get there we only ever
get to true enough
we never have the full truth and then
the second claim is basically
like in maps of meaning peterson um you
know basically makes a claim that
that his his his cosmological view that
he's putting forth there
is verified through multi-factor
you know multi-method uh verification
right that's that's the term that's the
scientific term for it so he's
he's saying okay if this pattern shows
up in the neurobiology and in the
cognitive science and in the
anthropology and in
the evolutionary biology then then i'm
gonna take that as
as true right in the same sense that you
know if i see something
and it's surprising to me if i can then
smell it and hear it and touch it then
i'll
accept that it's real in a way that that
my eyes
alone won't tell me that something's
real yeah so
those are the two things that i that
that i hear as sort of your your system
starts with
intuition and then moves into into
multi-factor
multi-method and then is grounded at
grounds out in pragmatism
it's something like that the difference
maybe between me jordan and i is that
i ground it above and he seems to
grounded below
it's like i i think that so so it's like
what is this the the the word of christ
who says blessed are those who did not
see and and and believe like that is
that if you have the pure intuition
that's where reality
lays not in the embodied pragmatic thing
because the embodimatic thing is messy
and it's kind of uh
it's it has variability and it's
sometimes it's it's a little off
but then the pattern is pure like it has
it it's a it's almost mathematical and
so you need both and i agree and you
totally need both but i ground
i let's say you could say something like
you just is going to be annoying to the
secular
to the secular people but i think i
ground my life
in in my faith in christ sure
rather than in the multiplicity and in
the
in the like uh the variability of
existence
and so it's it's it's a so that maybe
that's the difference between jordan and
i
so i think solidity comes from above
doesn't come from below
i i'd like to dig into that i i
i mean i'm i that one i struggle with
right
i understand that you struggle with i
because
so to go back to the beginning of the
conversation we're talking about how
sort of modernity reaches a point it's
like
you you break all the molecules down
into atoms and then you break the atoms
down into subatomic
particles and then you reach this point
at which it's just
uncertainty right and that's not what
you expected at all yeah
aristotle's potential is waiting for you
yeah so you end up
you you expect clockwork at the bottom
of reality and you end up with quantum
fields
and then and then you spend the last
like 60 years basically
unable to get anything that creates new
technological opportunities
out of trying to figure out what's at
the bottom of reality and
you know i don't understand quantum
physics i don't think anyone understands
quantum physics so if i butchered it and
what i say makes no sense because of it
you know forgive me
um but but so we so we end up there
right and essentially so much of science
is
is powered by reductionism and then
there's a point at which that doesn't
work anymore
and now we have complexity right we have
combinatorial explosion we have
complexity sciences systems thinking and
all of this gives us a way to understand
emergence
right so we know that things emerge
right that that you know the way i
understand we notice it i don't think
people understand it
okay but david bentley heart had a great
term he said he said he said rationalist
use the word emergence like you would
use the word magic it's like
your magic happens they just found
another word for it
so so a lot of people people who
talk about complexity that's exactly
what it sounds like to me and what
really helped me was understanding that
you can understand a dynamical system
as a system with two cost functions
right and that
when you put these two cost functions in
opposition to each other across an
equation
that they generate a random walk right
so
the the classic one the one that that's
you know really important all of science
is evolution right you have
mutation and sexual reproduction which
produces variation
and then you have selection which
selects from above among that and then
all these crazy things
emerge from it right so
so i get that right that makes sense to
me and i feel like i have really
really epistemologically sound ways of
getting there
right so
but then like when i listen to you or jp
marcel or someone else you talk about
this idea of emanation right
so i wanna i wanna look at an example
right
one of the things that the problem is
going to be easier to see emanation at a
human scale because it's
it has to do with intelligence it's
going to be harder to see it at a
biological like low
level it's there but it's harder to see
it's easier to see at a human level like
so if you deal with humans
uh okay so let's say
i i uh i found a
a city who i talked about this on my
channel recently it's like i'm
constantine
and i'm the king i'm the emperor and
then i found a city
and so i come and i do a sacred ritual i
will take a lance and i will like
walk behind an angel to like mark the
limit
of the city and and and so
so i actually give it a name i found it
i give it a name
and then it from that
will a city will will appear like people
will start to congregate
around that center and we'll start to
to to to do the things people in cities
do
around that sacred gesture that i did
okay so in the in the uh let's say
there's a
there is right nearby where i live
there's a town
that the first thing in the town that
was built was a church
and so they built a church which is a
common place a place of unity
where everybody congregates and worships
the same thing
and then you know a few decades later
there was an entire town built around
the church
so that's a form you could say like
that's a form of understanding causality
from above
which is you found you name you uh
you know you create a a coherence and
then
the world kind of comes in and manifests
uh
manifest from from you know so founding
a company
founding uh anything that is almost
human needs to have
an aspect of eminence that you can
easily perceive for it to
free to exist like for a group to exist
it has to have a name you have to name
it
right and so it's like you have a band
you get a bunch of guys together but
it's like
okay so if we're going to exist we need
a name and so then you name the band
and the name of the band like if you
name the band
uh the na a name that sounds like uh
like a pop band or if you name the band
the
the a name that sounds like a like a
death metal band because those actually
can be recognized in the name yeah it
will affect
so you couldn't have like a death metal
name and then
make pop songs because it'll be so
incoherent that it's going to break
apart
so you need to have so in the name and
in the image and in this kind of
founding
you need it you need a type of coherence
so that's a form of that's a form of a
form of eminence
but i mean there are so many but they're
a lot easier to see
for sure in human in the human sphere
but i mean can't you see that
that that emanation itself is derived
from an emergence
it's a it's a it's both happening at the
same time
right but you can't only see it as as as
emergent
like you can't it doesn't like at least
to me like the founding of uh
especially the idea of like the the idea
of the founding of something
because there's a whole idea that we
remember the founding
it's like why do we remember the
founding if it's just emergence like we
we re tell ourselves the story of the
founding of the united states
we tell ourselves the story of these
these sacred
uh moments that are the origin of
a community because it actually
binds the community together that's why
we remembered it and we tell the stories
and so like uh companies that have like
companies that have good founding
stories will
it'll actually affect like how how much
it how much it
lasts like you know yeah
um so it's but it but the thing is that
you can't only see it as emerg as
as as top down it has to be both at the
same time
that's the that's the bond of love you
could say like that's the communion of
love
uh there's a great uh quote by sam
maximus the confessor that i always like
to
to quote but people have heard it a
thousand times but it's he says that
as the as a person let's say a mystic
kind of raises above phenomena
and then starts to see the spiritual
essences kind of
rise up from the multiplicity he'll he
notices that there's no contradiction
like there's no contradiction between
those essences and the way they exist
embodied below those that's actually
that's actually how it works
so it's like it's it's that's why
reality is often described as the
meeting of lovers
right as a sexual union which is that
you need you need the desire of both
like you need the man
to you need the man to give and need the
woman to be to
to to give herself as well in the
different way that she does like
she has to be able to receive what the
man is giving and so that is the
that is the union of heaven and earth
which is both eminence and emergence
happening at the same time
and that's how you have a child that's
how you have the fruit of the
you know the next the another that's how
an identity is formed you could say
but i understand that it's harder for
you to see for me it's very easy to see
it's actually a lot easier to think that
way
than to think the other way yeah i mean
i'm i'm very much uh
grounded in in sort of a rational
materialist epistemology
and and i'm
i'm i feel like i'm going to need to
watch this part back
and mull on it to try to understand it
because
you know we're sort of obviously this is
this is tapping into the idea of the
forms and
and and this this idea that like
give me let me give you one little more
example like this is actually a pretty
good example
so so like imagine you have you have
something like
uh you have something like punk music
right so punk music appears right and so
actually music is just rock music right
yeah so why is it that why is it why is
there pump and so what do we name
punk but that keeps going right so you
all of a sudden because
there there's always variability it's
obviously no punk band is the same
but at some point you name that you name
the variability and so you're like
that's emo but then once you name the
variability
it has a causal function you're going to
have way more emo bands once you've
named emo
than before for sure i mean it was just
this variable thing that was kind of
and then people start to perceive that
there's something different and then
they give it a name
and then once they name it then it takes
body
and it starts to actually manifest as a
as a coherent whole
yeah so
the analogy that pops into my mind or
the the the example that
pops into my mind is of course parkour
right so
when i started parkour i was teaching
gymnastics and
the guy who there was a guy in my in the
gymnastics
sort of adult class that i attended who
they warned me was a crazy guy and he
was always doing
like weird off like fringe stuff to
gymnastics he was die rolling over vault
boxes and
swinging between you know um
uneven bar setups and swinging on the
rings and all the stuff that like
gymnasts don't do
and um and so i i discovered parkour and
i was like okay
dean that's his name like you should try
this because it seemed like the stuff he
was already doing
and he he then like pulls me into doing
parkour with him
and then we go out and he takes me to
all these places that he's already been
jumping and climbing around the city
that he didn't have a name for and he
had friends who he was doing this with
for years
right and
the same thing happens daniel bach is
one of those famous parkour athletes
like he he sees a guy doing
a wall flip because he's a caporista and
then he starts jumping around and
on the roofs in his city because he's
just intuits that somehow wall flips
mean you can jump off roofs um and then
and then oleg vorslav in in lithuania
does the same thing and so then like all
over the world the
as the parkour community sort of
scaffold itself up it finds all these
people who are already doing it
but they didn't have a name for it right
so
kids have always run jump and climb and
then some people
don't stop right or stop less than other
people
and so it's like the potential was
always there
but then there you go that's a good way
to understand it it was it was it was in
a potential form
yeah and then when it received a name
then that name became a causal
relationship
that is now people are people who
weren't doing that before
now start doing it because they can they
see in that name and in that communion
they notice a bee they see a being that
wasn't there before there was just a
scattered
potentiality within gymnastics within
military training within all these
different fields
uh and fit with under those fields
somehow we're a little strange maybe
that's why they kind of appeared as this
odd thing and then they're rebound in a
body with a name
and now here you go it has a causal
causal
causal uh relationship yeah so now you
know what emanation
but the emanation emerges right it's
both at the same time right
right like it's but it's a reality like
it's a pattern in reality parkour
right no of course not it it it was
it was all these implicit things
happening in this one specific place
and then somehow it got enough momentum
from this bubbling potentiality
that it catalyzed into something and
then it then it
received a name and once it had a name
then it could spread
right so that this is how god creates
adam
right so god takes the dust of the earth
right and also he doesn't and he gathers
it into one place
if it becomes a body that's the that's
the
emanation part that's right that's the
emergent part of immersion and then he
blows
the spirit into adam blows the breath
into adam and then that's the logos that
that would be the
you could see it as a logo so you could
see it just as the pattern right that's
what spirit
ultimately is the invisible part like
it's the invisible part of that body
the name is not visible and the identity
is not visible
the thing that binds it basically and so
it blows that invisible part into atom
and then adam exists and so it's
so so what you're describing is the same
like you you have you see all these
possibilities that are there and then
someone somehow starts to gather them
they start to gather
to accumulate and but they're still not
something they're they're kind of
and then all of a sudden something comes
like you someone something
names it from above and now that being
has
causal it can now reproduce itself
and and gather it more into its body
okay
so
that starts to feel like something
interesting to me right because
because because here's the problem with
the way that science has described
things
or one of the problems that i see is
that
is that it's hard to represent how a
thing that
that comes from emergence or from
reduced pieces becomes
agentic or causal right so when we when
we run through the scientific story
eventually we run out of human agency or
anything having agency
we we and i think this is a
like i think someone arguing that free
will doesn't exist
is a performative contradiction yeah
because by arguing with me that free
will doesn't exist
you are you're assuming that i have the
capacity to change
and that your action can change me or
that i can choose to believe or not
believe um
it's people who don't believe that free
will exist they don't maybe they don't
realize that they're the most dangerous
people in the world like they're
so dangerous because if you go to the
end of their argumentation
it's a scary thing because you can make
people change and the only
agent is some kind of
force whether it's con it's it's
convincing
or contriving that's what ends up being
it's like
you recognize the good and now i'm going
to
because people don't aren't free i'm
going to make them follow the good
it's going to be inevitable so okay so
you
sorry i take you on a tangent there yeah
maybe we'll touch that i don't know i
wanted to go back to this idea though
that
that that within within our
understanding of reality we have to have
something that allows us to
grok how something that emerges then
becomes a causal factor in itself right
yeah
that parkour emerges and then emanates
right but in this in this sense
emergence precedes emanation
right um it precedes it as possibility
yeah and and then it but then it does
not identity
is what binds it together and so you're
right like
saying gregor nissa says basically he
says this the physical
comes first and the spiritual comes
after let's say
and so it's like it's almost like uh
it's it's like desire comes first you
could call it that a question
it's a question comes first what is this
yeah there's something which is
appearing on my horizon a puzzle
and i'm like what is this and then it
gets an answer
a name an identity and once it has an
identity
then it has causal causal factor and so
like you can imagine it like that like
you have you have a bunch of parkour
people that aren't yet parkour guys
who are noticing like you're noticing
these
a puzzle it's like what is this like
there's something
going on like there there's something
calling like what is
there's there's something calling from
the ground right like asking
to be asking for a master like asking to
be
to be contained and then once it is
contained
then it then like you said it then it
starts to have causal factor
so you can understand like that like a
question and an answer you need both and
the question obviously comes first or
else
why would you speak right like why would
you speak and you can see it like uh
even like in the way that christian
theology developed it's always like that
it's like
that there was always a problem first
like christian theology never developed
as just straightforward
giving giving uh like teaching like
there's a problem
and now there has to be an answer and
that answer
becomes becomes the the the road or the
way but the problem always happens first
like the question
the puzzle let's say
i'm going to back up a second because
this just what you described
it hit this so many times and this is i
i just really think the fir
the first stanza of the dao de ching is
so
profound right
the way that can be spoken is not the
eternal way
the nameless is the mother of all things
the name
gives rise to the ten thousand things i
think a lot of people from the west they
pay attention to the first
two stanzas in that versus in that
stanza
and they forget the name yeah right
which is the logos really
yes yeah yeah i think i think it is
right so you
so you start with undifferentiated
potential
or you start with mystery right what we
can describe
what we can model is always an
insufficient description of reality
and then there's undifferentiated
potential and that's
everything comes out of that it has to
come out of that and then
in order for it to come out of it though
it has to become named
in order for parkour to not just be in
order for our core to grow and spread
and become a causal factor in the world
it has to be named it has to become
a defined characteristic of the know
yeah
so in so in the bible it's in
christianity there's a sense that the
undifferentiated
gets separated into two so you have
the waters below and the waters above
right and so the waters below
act like let's say the undifferentiated
in the sense of chaos and potential
yeah the waters above act as the
undifferentiated in the sense of
something which is beyond uh beyond
uh causa beyond causality or
transrational
and then comes down into the name or
into into causality
and so so you can under so it's
important to it's a little important to
distinguish those two because they're
not they don't function exactly the same
uh but they they say ultimately
infinitely they end up being the same
but in terms of our experience
they end up being different and so
there's a there's a space of intuition
from which the names come from
and there's a space of potential or or
chaos
out of which let's say potential is is
brought out of
and so then the name comes down and then
comes down from heaven
and then manifests itself on the
potential
and then you have then you have a b
but that that's already there like in
the in the dow you have a sense
uh you do have a sense in which they
don't totally differentiate those two
like
at least in that first out that first
setting where it's like there's
undifferentiated and then but there has
to be
anyways i don't want to go to
metaphysics too much let's continue on
this would be too complicated but
but just understand at least like in
christian metaphysics you have a sense
in which
there's there's this separation and then
the world kind of exists in this space
which is
created by the separating of two
differentiations let's say like yeah
chaos and like
supra rational and then that comes down
into the world
so in in the mesopotamian myths you have
tiamat and absolute right
yep the waters above and the water is
below right yeah
this is water in the clear water and
then and then in the
in in genesis i believe my camera died
um i have to move to my other webcam
um
[Music]
it says god separates the waters right
that's like this
one of the first few things he does yeah
and then the idea is that the the
joining of the waters
becomes the place of life like the place
of life
and that goes all the way through
scripture it goes all the way even into
jesus talking to the samaritan woman
and she's next to a well which is the
lower waters and he says i will give you
a fountain that springs into eternity
so he's saying i'm going to give you the
living water and you're going to be the
the lower water and then that's how the
the
that's how the world exists like those
two joining together
like i i find this kind of mythological
frame
to be very useful and and i feel like it
it
i hit the end of rational materialism i
feel like right
i don't perhaps that sounds
egotistical but like when i listen to to
sam harris i'm like i get
everything you say it it's all it's all
coherent within a certain system
but it's like you have decided not to
look at this thing
that says that you have to step outside
of that right
and i think essentially like once you
really think about godall's
incompleteness theorem and heisenberg's
uncertainty principle it's like
you're you're stuck it's like that that
doesn't work and
and yeah i think hume's odd and his
distinction
is true right and we we need something
else and so
these stories and like when i listen to
you and i listen to peterson i'm like
that that there is insight there that
i'm not getting
from from reading evolutionary biology
right or physics um
and and and i've you know i've crafted
this idea within my own work of like
what is the heroic archetype what are we
what are we seeking
so like through peterson i got really
into the idea of the heroic archetype i
was like
what are we doing when we do parkour we
go out and we confront
chaotic potential and extract our own
character out of it basically
go do a jump that we've never done
before that's potential
right yeah and through confronting the
fear and the challenge and everything
that goes along with that
there's something beautiful some gold
some
that we take away from that
confrontation with gas so then i started
asking like
what is a hero right a hero is is
someone who
and it kind of like through some of
peterson's ideas and other stuff i came
up with this idea that like
well first to here has to be able to
recognize that there's a problem like
the first thing you do the first problem
that a parkour athlete has is actually
being able to see where the
problems are right yeah how do i go and
find places to do
jumps right so the first thing is is
being able to see the problem
and then the second is like articulation
of it right how do i
how do i recognize what's going to allow
me to accomplish this
and then the next you have to or not
only it's like you have to be able to
recognize a holy place
like a place that is capable of rece
because if i mean obviously if you're
standing in front of a field it's like
that place is not
does not have the right potential for me
to engage
in what in what i want to accomplish so
you need to find like a
a sacred i people are going to be angry
that i use that but
relatively at a lower level something
akin to a sacred space
that when you see it you recognize it
has the potentiality you need in order
to embody something particular
yeah i mean the the way that i react the
way that i interact with the trees and
the nature that i
train in is a relationship of sacredness
for me for sure
um it has this sense of of helping me
transcend and
connecting with me to something that's
beyond right um
so i have no problem with that um but
and i don't think my audience will maybe
the
the some of the christians will but um
yeah that's hilarious it's like it's
like here's the christians using that
you're saying
christians will react to this so it's so
so
so first is is vision right horus second
is
is articulation right um say
socrates or something like that then the
next is uh is
emotional wherewithal to be able to
confront the problem
right to have the equanimity to stand in
front of our challenge
and then the next is the physical
strength to accomplish and the last is
is the physical skills to to have those
embodied
capacities right and build all that it's
like
and then as i looked at that i was like
this describes a human being who's
achieved greatness who's achieved virtue
but it says nothing about goodness and
in fact you could apply
all of these capacities to being evil
the genghis khan is probably really good
at all of these things
right yeah exactly and so then i asked
well
what what is
what what brings us into the good and
and for vicky vicki's
episode 16 of awakening from the meaning
crisis agape
is the answer it's the only answer that
i've come up with that works
i can't i can't get below that right the
only way that i can define the good
is is being in relationship to reality
such that i am acting from love that
wants to bring good into being
right it's like that's that's the
highest principle so then i've like
almost got down to this set of axioms so
basically like
you're fundamentally you have to respect
the mystery you have to accept that
there's always going to be things
outside of your own capacity to
understand
and then you have to be in service of
love right and then you have to
to do that through truth and the
cultivation of virtue
so that's that's what i've derived from
this but here's my hesitation and here
here's where
i'm trying to imagine myself especially
in the audience perspective
the woman at the well she represents the
lower
jesus represents the higher here's a
relationship of hierarchy between male
and female
right and for
so you have an intuition let's say that
chaos
that chaos maps to the feminine
but for many people that that intuition
runs maybe the opposite way or that
that that that creates a reaction of the
higher waters also map on the famine
okay there you go that well that's
that's actually
in a way not exactly but there's a way
in which
this is this is the these are the
mysteries that we're not supposed to
talk about
but let's say that saying ephraim the
syrian talks of the womb of god
he talks about he talks of the divine
womb out of which
the the divine persons uh emerge which
is the divine essence
and there's a very mysterious thing
going on there
but anyways yeah so go ahead continue
what you're going to say
so if we take this
intuitive approach and then some sort of
pragmatism and some sort of
of a multi-multi-factor um
we still run into the reality that
people have different intuitions or
different
orientations symbolic systems that they
operate within and there's not
necessarily
i one there's conflict there
that's what it feels like right yeah and
and one one reaction to that is sort of
i think the verve key response which is
let's step outside of the narratives and
treat them as instrumental
rather than existing within them right
and then we can have the religion that
is not a religion
and then we don't have to deal with the
fact that that
that um
that that the islamic description the
muslim description of
of the of of christ is is not congruent
with the christian description of christ
right like he he he's respected there
but but the meaning of what he did
isn't possible to glean from the the
description that they give
and so so there there's inherently a
potential for conflict and i
i don't know if that's the same in
buddhism and taoism versus christianity
i tend to think that they're more
potentially congruent but
but whatever there there are going to be
places where that's not
where the where the the two systems are
going to be in conflict
right and how do we
how do we navigate those waters with
without
a clear epistemology sorry you broke
down how do you said how do we navigate
those waters
without a clearer epistemology yeah
um so
obviously okay so there are many things
to say one
is that we can only perceive the pure
pattern from
an embodied place and
and to pretend that you can or to
pretend that you are
leaving that is to
delude yourself this is what i think and
so i think that
the position or the universalist
position of saying i'm going to step
outside of these narratives in order to
be able to see them all
is is a delusion it's still a narrative
it's just that you don't you don't see
it it's the it's the narrative the tower
of babel
it's the narrative of you know and it
and it doesn't
and what it leads to is it actually will
lead to to uh
fragmentation it'll lead to a breakdown
the desire to kind of
lead to not having a common not having a
real
common narrative and so therefore it'll
be like a competition
that's where it's going to be even more
so a competition of narratives
because you have to embody something
like you have to you have to be in the
in a path
like you have to be on on a road going
somewhere and you say like i'm gonna
stand above all these roads
and i'm gonna say well actually i
noticed that all these roads lead to the
same place but you're not you're not
doing it you're not
on the you're not actually doing it
um so that's one thing like that's one
thing in terms of the
of of the of that of that problem is i
think that
the idea of saying that someone is going
to
not engage or kind of rise above uh
is uh it's it's similar to brett
weinstein when he says
it's similar to sam harris or brett
weinstein when they when they say
something like don't you see like when
when brett weinstein just says don't you
see that this is obviously moral
and you're like what you don't see your
own story like you always are you're in
a story
to me it's just inevitable unless you're
like in the mystical vision
like once you like if you enter into a
mystical vision and you enter into
let's say kind of this this moment of
pure transcendence where you're
completely
united with god and completely united
with the infinite in every way
then yes but then when you when you talk
about it
when you come back down you still you
now have to give it flesh and body and
story it has to retake
body and flesh for it to exist so
where where i get really caught in this
in all these discussions is again is
it comes back to scientific epistemology
works
and delivers truth in a certain way but
it doesn't deliver all the truths that
we need
right but if we adopt any other system
that collapses that then then it's
really a problem right um
so so we have to we have to do that and
what what where i get hung up is
like i i've said that i think i'm a
non-theistic christian and
the the i think part is a really
important qualifier
and i can i can go a little deeper there
but um
but when i listen to to a lot of
christians
describe their relationship to
the resurrection what i hear them doing
is trying to operate
a a logical coherent system that looks
something like science where they're
making all of these exceptions to how
they would
treat a actual scientific question right
and so so in terms of the resurrection
of christ yes yeah
yeah what i tend to think is
that's it but that's also because like
look i i i don't deny
the sad state of christianity like i
really do not deny that
i think that christianity has become uh
you know which one of the reasons why it
has led to where it is i think it's part
of the bigger story i've talked about
this many times before but
none it's nonetheless happening like
christianity is dying and it's
and and in part of that is has been
christians embracing of a really strange
materialism and a
kind of scientism as their worldview um
and so the idea of of understanding the
resurrection is
you have to understand the resurrection
as okay as a
something something like strong
emergence you could say like something
as
something as a a phenomena which is
which actually gives you the key to all
phenomena
and so it doesn't it does it can't
completely
act on the same level as the phenomena
that it's that it's
that it's giving the unity to and
all miracles are like that miracles are
not just weird uh
are not just like weird exceptional
things that happen that's never the case
it's not just like
something unexplainable happens and
that's a miracle miracles are not that's
not what they are
miracles are always higher up on the
level of pattern
that is they're actually embodying
the pattern of reality at a level beyond
the normal
usual levels of causality and so what it
looks like
is actually looks like it's it looks
like it's
it's like it's like it's pulling in the
multiplicity
into itself in a way that doesn't seem
to make sense at the lower level
just like qualities of of certain beings
you
if you try to look at just the the lower
elements
when you you're like well this doesn't
make sense like why is water wet oxygen
and hydrogen are neither of those you
know and so how is it that i get to wet
you can't find it there it's immersion
right it's like a but it's a strong
emergency because it but
it's more than that it's not arbitrary
because that looks arbitrary like
the the miracles of christ and
especially the resurrection
is like once you realize that that let's
say
once you you see resurrection then
you're like actually you know what
that's how that's how reality works
resurrection is something that i see
every
day i see resurrection all the time i
get that symbolically
right i do i mean like when you describe
it
it makes total sense to me but it
doesn't it doesn't establish to me
in any sense that that that i could that
i could
believe that christ died and was
resurrected in the same way that i
believe
that my dog is scratching itself behind
me or that or even that
that that evolution happened right
because i can verify aspects of
evolution in a way that i can't verify
that story
and you're you're you're making an
argument from a sort of um
it makes sense of things right it's like
the cs lewis argument
like it's a key to actually
comprehending so therefore there's a
truth to it but
like you're not a biblical literalist
right you don't believe that that the
description of genesis
is true in the sense that it falsifies
the existence of dinosaurs
uh i i don't think that i don't think
that the description in genesis
is a scientific description okay if
that's what you expect so but
but i think it's transcription my
goodness the best way to describe the
world
is is the death and resurrection of
christ true as a scientific fact
uh well you mean in
a scientific fact in the sense that you
could prove it scientifically how could
you prove it scientifically it happened
2000 years ago
exactly so so here here's my perspective
on this
i feel like a lot of christians feel
like that has to be asserted with
certainty
within and then they they're they're
within that materialist frame and i i
don't exactly know your relationship to
this i haven't
i don't i don't know but i believe the
resurrection is real i believe that it
happened i believe that the description
that are in scripture are the best way
to describe what happened so let me let
me ask you if this would make sense
because
the way that i could imagine myself
relating to this and i don't precisely
relate to it this way is something like
i need to have access to scientific
epistemology and if i operate that
system and i
ask the question of christ's death and
resurrection the answer i get is
probably not right but i know that that
system itself is
incomplete and it cannot tell me for
certain what's happening
now there is a broader ontology that i
exist within that i think within and
in order to to make my ontology work
the resurrection actually is key
so so my question so let's let me ask
you a question like have you ever
experienced
a miracle no okay so have you ever
experienced
a hiding experience where
the world around you the causality
around you
which was not related to your experience
all of a sudden merged with your
experience
i like like uh like
like uh that doesn't that doesn't i
don't know what would you call
synchronicity if that ever happened to
you
where the inside and the outside like
join together
i i mean i have had moments where it
seemed like
so i i interviewed paul vander clay
recently right
and paul had been talking about
superhero stories right and he published
a superhero story the day that
uh jordan peterson was satired as red
skull
by ac coats right the day that that came
out
it's like well that's a strange
coincidence right and i've had those
strange coincidences happen in my life
now as someone who's trying to operate
within rational materialism
i just think coincidences happen right
um
so when people talk about synchronicity
that feels like they're operating some
kind of epistemology that doesn't make
any sense to me
all right um well i guess it's hard
because if you haven't like i mean
you've had little experiences like that
but
there are moments in your life like i
think most people have these moments
where
the the outside world and the the inside
world seems to
come together where all of a sudden the
world outside seems to be wanting you to
see something
oh yeah i mean i have those experiences
why don't you believe them because what
i understand about
the way the human mind works from an
evolutionary perspective
makes me um
skeptical of our story making and
pattern making
behavior right we know that this can
mislead us in important ways
right and and when i see people and this
is the other the flip side of that like
the background that i've talked about
when i see people who become
who fall in love with this story that
they have in their mind of how
reality is laying itself out and making
them
giving them some sense of transcendence
those people become very dangerous to me
and very
likely to be full of [ __ ] yeah well
that's also because usually they're not
embedded in like a bigger pattern like
they
they usually don't have some they don't
they're not a part of a normal
but what i'm trying to what i'm trying
to try to get you to see
is that there are moments where there's
a causality of meaning which happens
and that the the the multiplicity of the
world
in its mechanical causalities doesn't
account for the causality of meaning
doesn't account for the fact that um
you know all of a sudden like i have to
deal with certain
problem and all of a sudden everything
around me is screaming at me
like everything i see is screaming at me
to deal with this problem like
it all these weird accidents all these
weird things as there's like this this
moment where all of this kind of comes
together
and i can only see that as having
it can only be reasonable if i
understand
that it's it's it's joined together as a
body right it's it's joy
all these multiple elements are joined
together as a body
and they're they're waiting to be
they're waiting to find a name let's say
and so that's that's actually it's kind
of like that's how
at least that's how so so i mean a good
example like let me find another let me
give you an example from what i gave you
before it's like
uh constantine founds
the the city right and then all of a
sudden
it becomes a city but the mechanical
causality
like the guy the cart with the with the
wheels and the guy driving the cart
like that mechanical causality has
nothing to do
like he's his card is going to
constantinople
to become part of that city but
the the the mechanic all the mechanical
causation has nothing to do
you can't find it in the mechanical
causality the reason
why he's going to constantinople the
reason why it's going to constantinople
is in the
meaning
i'm not sure that's true i mean i think
so so that's a little part but like
the thing is that sometimes that becomes
bigger like it actually becomes bigger
and it starts to
it starts to grow into and to accumulate
in ways that
can only be described as miracles and so
it's like if you've never experienced
that i don't know like i've experienced
it
quite a bit uh and
but but i don't know like and so so what
i would tell you that the resurrection
is like the the the is the keystone of
that
process is like the top version of that
because it actually reveals
how death can come together and become
alive like how something dead
things that don't have any coherence
with each other
can join into a body and that they can
find
life like that's what that's basically
what resurrection is
um and so yeah anyways there's no way
that i'm gonna
i'm gonna like convince you in this
discussion and we've already been going
for two hours anyways i should probably
go okay um
one thing i verbally says that i really
like is people have mystical experiences
say on psilocybin or whatever and they
come back and they have the sense that
they have the most profound
meaning that they've had in their life
and they have a lesson
but those lessons can be completely
incongruent with each other
and the positive impact on somebody's
life is
is the same whether they come back and
say god is definitely real or god is
definitely not real
um so this this sense of the miraculous
like
i don't maybe it's just broken in me all
right
like like like so
you know the cognitive anthropologists
say that that the the origin of
religious belief is overactive agency
detection
and that's an evolutionary feature and
that's reasonable to me
and and maybe i have less of that than
other people i used to think
listen to what they say it's hallel look
at listen to the terms they use
overactive agency detection like
on what ground do they stand to
to to tell us what the limit of agency
is like do they even know what agency is
like
how are they even saying that i mean so
seeing a face in a cloud is there an
actual face in the cloud or does your
from an evolutionary
standpoint is there an actual face in
front of you
like if i look at your face is there a
face there there's pixels on the screen
right have you ever have you ever
have you ever had the experience of not
recognizing someone you know and then
all of a sudden you recognize them
they become the person like is that is
that scientifically materially is that
real like a face is not a is not a
it's not a scientific concept a face is
meaning
and so the idea of seeing a face in the
cloud why an evolutionary
biologist would be bothered why would
see that as less real than seeing the
face in front of you
to me is mind-boggling like why is it
seeing a face in a cloud less real in
terms of
pure biological like understanding
like because there is no reason for for
for these like in terms of
evolution pragmatically pragmatically me
interpreting your face as a face allows
me to
interface and interact with you whereas
if i try to do the same thing with the
cloud usually that's considered
craziness
i mean you never see the face in the
cloud well i've seen their face in the
cloud but i don't talk to it
and i don't hear it talking back to me
uh
but let's say that that would happen
like let's say that that could happen
sure uh that might have a causal it
might have a causal
uh function especially in a world that
is totally coherent
like in a world that's completely
coherent that might have a causal
function that you
might struggle to understand like seeing
a cosmic face
or seeing a bigger face and that face
informing you
of some meaning that could i think that
i think that biologically just in terms
of evolutionary thinking i think that
could happen
and that it could it could it could be a
way for a group to cohere
it could be a way for uh it could do all
kinds of things
um well yes um and it could be real like
it could be it could be really you're
really seeing your face in the cloud
i don't know about that part as real as
seeing your face
like like i'm saying a face doesn't
exist in the material world
well it doesn't face is a is a meaning
is that is there is a it's
a way right because because
like my face or your face they're made
up of muscles and bone
and blood and nerves and they exist
through an evolutionary process to give
us the capacity to
to see and smell and eat and now to
express to each other like human faces
are
way more variable than say wolf faces
and it's because we
need the ability to to easily recognize
each other
through vision and the ability to then
communicate effectively through faces
right okay so
i know i've got it i've got it i've got
it listen to this listen to this okay
so can an emoji have a causal
effect yes
is there a face there no there's a
symbol there
but we recognize it as a face and it has
causal effect like you can actually
change the way you
act change the way you feel change the
way you interact with
with the with what you're seeing yes and
so the same for a face in a cloud like
you see a face in a cloud it can have a
causal effect and it's a real causal
effect
yeah no but it's not a real face
an emoji has a real causal effect but
it's not a real face
right so i just find that funny that
you're saying that
like as a as a materialist i find it
funny that you would say that an emoji
isn't a real
face but this like sack of flesh in
front of me
that's a real face well
the the emoji contains aspects of what a
face is
because it's a symbol it's a faces
a face is a pattern that's what a face
is and so the face is a pattern that has
that has it embodies itself in the
people around me
uh so that i can recognize them but it's
a pattern and so if i draw a face on a
piece of paper i'm
i'm also manifesting the pattern you're
representing
at least and i recognize it and it can
have causal and it can have causal
effect
sure like if i yeah so to go back to
just
just to go back to our active agency
detection
um the idea is that you hear a bear in
the woods
if it's possible that there's a bear in
the woods whether it's there or not and
that this is
was important to our survival and that
is this the way
that that that that mind was built then
inclines us to this capacity for for
religious belief um
i i used to have a sense that that
aspect of me was just
not as turned up as some other people
right yeah um
i think that may just be hubris
right another way to to to interpret my
particular world view is just that i've
trained myself
very intensely to view the world from a
specifically rational materialist frame
for whatever reasons right as a reaction
to all the crazy hippies around me
um but uh
but but the thing is that when you talk
about
the the pattern sort of boom
synchronicity all that stuff
i i don't have any way i don't have any
way to
to sort that from hearing the same thing
from
my hippie friend who just went on a deal
yeah i understand but
the emoji the emoji example i gave you
is probably a really good one in the
sense that
that emoji has it's just a bunch of
pixels or ink or something on a piece of
paper
uh but because it participates in a
pattern it can have a causal effect on
and so so it's actually doing that like
it's doing it's a little
miracle like a very little one yeah very
very small one
well this is then the ques well this is
where we get into the question
and we're gonna prob i'm gonna rep i'm
gonna save the problem and then we'll
just gonna let it go because we can't we
can't go in
but the problem is is the pattern just
emergent from the human mind or is it
something more
and that i mean that that question to me
doesn't mean anything
like it well because it's like is it
just what's the every time someone use
the words just
to me it's like i i it's like a little
it's like a little itch that i have it's
like what does that mean just
emerging from the the human mind is part
of reality it's like it
it's so there is no just emerging from
the human mind
it has to it has to be the human mind is
there it ha it came about and so it's
part of the world like
so so it's not it can't be just
there's no there's no there's no just so
um hopefully this works um
we'll see we'll see it'll be interesting
uh
ivan and uh alyosha karamazov
right yeah they're not
real human beings we're not real human
beings
they represent things that are real and
powerful and important
and they have causal of impact on the
world but they were never
flesh and blood human beings right
they're not the same
they're not the same level of they don't
have the same level
they don't have the the same level of
existence as you do they have
they have so
so they are characters let's say
that are that whose meaning is
utterly collapsible to human psychology
on one level maybe i mean
the reason why we recognize them as
having value is because they're
embodying
things they're embodying patterns in a
way that
that resonate with us right so it's not
just
it's not they're not just collapsible to
human psychology is that they
they're they're embodying patterns that
we want to attend to
yeah right and there's a reason why we
attend to things attention is not
arbitrary like it's not just
it's not just uh reducible to human
psychology it has to do with
a whole level of things that make us
exist in the world or not exist and
there's
you know there's a bunch of stuff
involved um
so so so i have this
you know i i would say i'm a non-theist
right in the sense that i don't
think that the objective the question of
the objective
existence of god is answerable or
particularly fruitful
right but i would say that i i feel
fairly certain within a rational
materialist frame that god
is a psychological reality of human
beings
but within that same frame i can't claim
that it's a
object outside of me like i believe that
if i walk by a tree today and i
leave and walk somewhere else and i'm
it's no longer in my
field of attention or um or awareness
the tree doesn't disappear right it's
not simply a psychological
aspect of my existence it is
obviously a lot of what it is to me is
psychological and symbolic but the
tree's still there
and that's that's materialism right yeah
yeah but god is not there
like god is not outside of your frame
god is not
god is not a thing yeah that god is not
a thing and this is like this is a
totally orthodox
like i always tell people if you think
god is a thing then i'm i'm i feel
better telling you that god doesn't
exist
like if that's what you're thinking if
you think existence limits itself to
things that can be identified and
quantified and and all that then i would
say god doesn't exist because
even in that very traditional christian
theology god
is as the source of all being god is
beyond
name beyond characteristics beyond
that's what god is
god is the source of characteristic and
being and and
and all names and all essences you know
come from
that infinite non being and non-being
joined together
like same action says god is being a
non-being
do you think do you believe or
do you believe that god has
self-awareness in a sense that we would
recognize
i how can i say this like the best way
to understand that would be to say that
i believe that god has what you would
call something like infinite
awareness and our awareness is actually
a participation in that
infinite awareness like our intelligence
comes from
god and so so so it's like
because we can't that's how that's
actually the best way to to me to
explain consciousness like
because it's very difficult to explain
consciousness like
consciousness emanates from an infinite
consciousness
and that we are we are sparks
let's say that our personhood is a spark
of the divine
so i don't think google has a
consciousness
right or self-awareness google does not
does not
think about being google but there's no
there's no inside of the google
experience it's an intelligence and it
is causal and it is an agent that
that that we interact with but it's not
self-aware
but you also can't verify that in any no
i can't i cannot verify that i don't
know that that's true i can't verify
that in you
like i can't verify exactly right i
could be a philosophical zombie
rape i need to go man i'm sorry no this
is this is
i think we should we should like i loved
i really enjoyed it i enjoy our
conversation but
should probably we should probably set
up another one because i think because i
i think we we there are more places to
go but i actually i need there are the
things i need to do i i also need to go
um i'm glad that you you enjoyed it i
felt like this was really fruitful i
it stayed pretty close to what i was
hoping but it definitely went in
different directions and
i really enjoyed it and i look forward
to for future conversations yeah and i
will definitely
be i'll really be happy to share this
because i do feel like you
if you do feel like you're making like a
real genuine
like effort to to to to understand what
i was talking about and i
and i feel like you're i feel like you
get it at least most of it let's say
yeah
and so so that that's that brings me joy
i guess
awesome i'm glad that we could provide
some joy and hopefully a better bridge
because it didn't feel like it was
getting built and and i i think i i
i'm genuinely really impressed by the
power of your insights and i want people
to be able to absorb them
um and not get tripped upon the the
language yeah yeah yeah
so i appreciate thank you very much all
right let's set up another another time
for
another discussion absolutely thank you
all right bye jonathan